spider-man to welcome back to my series
of spider-man reviews leading up to
civil war I've already covered the first
film and now we're going to talk about
the second film which some feel is
actually better than the first one
spider-man 2 I remember it was in the
afternoon I remember waiting outside the
theater and as I was waiting to go in I
noticed that around me were all these
kids that I knew I went to school with
and it was a strange feeling because I
was very much like Peter Parker when I
was in school nerd got picked on a lot
not a lot of friends and it was weird to
see a lot of the cool kids in line with
me for spider-man two and realizing you
guys like this shit too and you're just
too afraid to admit it for me spider-man
2 is better than the first one it is a
film that flushes out its characters
much better it actually feels like a
film
it doesn't necessarily feel like a
superhero movie but the movie flushes
out its characters the characters are so
strong they're so compelling each
character has something driving him or
her and each person feels as if they
have emotions that are earned and where
at times you might think the pacing is
dwindling a little bit because we
haven't seen a lot of spider-man lately
you realize as the film goes on that
building the hero not necessarily the
costumed hero but Peter Parker as a hero
building up his character building up
MJ's character giving Aunt May more
things to think about introducing the
great Alfred Molina as Otto Octavius and
giving him a great backstory and having
all of these people be so realistic and
so grounded that when the crazy awesome
superhero stuff is happening you can get
so invested in it because you really do
care about the people behind the suits
and that's where it really shines
spider-man 2 is one of the best
superhero movies ever made I think paga
Joe's 29 minute delivery is a promise
man I know to you a promise means
nothing but to me it's serious the
opening pizza stuff reminded me of the
game this is actually one of the best
movie based games ever made spider-man 2
the game you have to deliver a lot of
pizzas and get them there on time it's
tons of fun I had a great time with this
game when I was a kid one of the reasons
spider-man 2 is in my opinion the best
spider-man film we have seen yet is
because it understands the character of
Peter Parker and spider-man the duality
there and
what needs to be present for his
character to work and that is you got to
keep beating on this guy you just got to
keep pounding him into the ground and
that's what this film does you care so
much about Peter his grades are failing
he's slipping at school he can't figure
out how to approach the woman he loves
and Mary Jane Watson and she's dating
someone and this guy wants to marry her
and Harry is pissed at Peter because
Harry thinks the spider-man killed his
father and Peter's the guy who's taken
all spider-man's pictures so his friends
are falling out the love of his life
doesn't want to have anything to do with
him because Peter can't make it to an
eight o'clock curtain to see Mary Jane
in a play a shoelace you might want to
can I help you
and that's why I love these first two
Raimi films so much they clearly have an
understanding of this character it
really does show what it would be like
for a normal kid to be spider-man and
how hard that would be in fact Stanley
has said that the reason spider-man
wears a mask is because he wants to hide
his fear from his enemies whereas say
someone like Batman wants to inflict
fear into his enemies spider-man wants
to hide that and that's so beautiful
it's a beautiful thing you have a real
human kid who's trying to make a
difference but he's just a kid in fact
in this film after the brilliant train
scene and he's unconscious there's a guy
looking down at him and he's like he's
just a kid no older than my son the bits
of conflict that were set up between
Harry and Peter in the first film all
that comes back to play in spider-man 2
because Peter isn't telling Harry where
spider-man is because he is spider-man
but Harry doesn't know that there's this
heartbreaking scene at this gala event
where Harry slaps Peter in the face two
times he's drunk and right after that
happens you learn that Mary Jane has
agreed to marry this astronaut guy I
mean this movie just pounds Peter Parker
into the dirt it even sets up conflict
between Aunt May and Peter because Peter
finally admits to her in this film that
he was present and partially responsible
for Uncle Ben's death it's a very
well-written movie and I got to talk
about Alfred Molina this guy nailed Otto
Octavius I mean he was so good and I
loved the practical arm effects as well
that are behind him most of the time I
must talk about the brilliant hospital
scene it's one of my favorite scenes in
any superhero film
it's built like a horror movie I mean
it's very Evil Dead and some people said
it was too violent but I don't think
that way at all because it needed to be
there to set up how destructive Otto
Octavius could really be if he let
himself give in to this I do have some
issues with the movie and one of them is
that I feel like MJ is way too harsh on
Peter for missing her play she really
really lays it on him and I know she's
dealing with a lot of emotional turmoil
it just to me it just feels a little too
harsh and almost like it was just a plot
device like we need to have this happen
so that this can happen so we'll have
her get really really absurdly pissed
about this play thing and just move on
from there but when everything is really
crushing down on Peter to the point
where he just can't take it anymore he's
about to break he has this almost inner
dreamlike vision where he talks to Uncle
Ben Uncle Ben is reaching out to him
saying take my hand be spider-man and
he's like no I'm spider-man no more I've
seen this movie multiple times but re
watching it as an adult I teared up it's
really powerful and it's because you're
watching a person give up he's done he
doesn't want to do what he's meant to do
anymore because he just can't take it
now after those tears went away it leads
to the raindrops keep falling on my head
scene which I love
it's so insane I remember the first time
I saw in the theater I was like what
this is dumb then as I rewatched it
again especially the freeze-frame shot
oh my dear Lord it's so Alerus as I
rewatched it again it grew on me to the
point where I was like this is just
original and different this is so Sam
Raimi this is just a director who's like
this is my style deal with it there's a
great shot in the scene where Parker
sees police cars drive by he looks at
him for a second and then takes this
absurdly humongous bite of a hot dog
like I don't give a shit as I said I do
have a few issues with this movie one of
them was that MJ seemed too harsh the
other one is this burning building scene
that feels like such attacked on
addition almost like a reshoot like
somebody had some screening said hey
there's not enough action and they're
like alright we'll just put a burning
building scene and we'll use the score
from the burning building scene in the
first spider-man and we'll just have
them save a kid for some reason and yeah
I just don't feel like it has a place in
this story I feel like you really could
delete the entire thing
so there's a bank sequence where auto
robs a bank and Peter just runs off
leaves Aunt May there and then comes
back a spider-man saves the day and
everything Aunt May never questions him
for running off wouldn't you be like hey
why did you abandon me and then suddenly
reappear so the only way that that
cannot be a flaw for me is if Aunt May
knows that Peter spider-man or at least
suspects because in the film she gives
him this incredibly heartfelt speech
directly at him like saying we need
spider-man and so she doesn't know then
she is really laying it on thick but I
have a feeling she suspects it's just
that spider-man 3 which we'll talk about
soon never talks about that at all it's
just sort of abandoned also I have to
admit spider-man 1 is paced far better
spider-man 2 is really only a few
minutes longer than spider-man 1 and it
does feel considerably longer spider-man
1 does have more action it has more fun
scenes and it's largely paced better
than spider-man 2 because 2 is more of a
drama than the first one was and it
takes its time with its characters which
in my opinion isn't a negative another
kind of stupid part is that Otto needs
tritium to continue his experiment this
is the thing that killed his wife it
almost blew of the city and turn him
into Doc Ock which this is not the
stupid part the student part is that he
has to go find Peter to figure out where
spider-man is because Harry makes a deal
with Otto that if you kill spider-man
I'll give you all the tritium you need
when he finds Peter he like launches him
against a brick wall and could have
killed him he does not know that Peter
is spider-man if you really wanted Peter
Parker to help you find spider-man you
might not want to completely
incapacitate him and possibly paralyze
him nevertheless it leads into one of my
favorite action scenes of all time the
train scene this thing is frickin
awesome there are so many cool moments
in this scene like Spidey balancing
himself at the last second by spinning
this web or nearly getting sideswiped by
another train jumping into the train
around the bars there's so many amazing
moments him getting dragged on the
pavement then swinging to get back to
the train as soon as possible this
eventually leads into Harry finding out
that Peter is spider-man and it's a very
good scene because it's quick and you
expect it almost to be like this
drawn-out thing but it's so fast this
movie doesn't let too many subplots bog
get down so that you forget what the
real story is so we get to the big
finale sequence of course MJ's a damsel
in distress again and you kind of deal
with it this time it's like okay yeah
all right
but just don't do it again but they did
and we'll talk about that soon Doc Ock
and Spidey are fighting it's awesome
it's exciting
MJ finds out finally that Peter is
spider-man and it's like this feeling of
oh thank you finally now he doesn't have
to explain everything anymore she can
look at him and know exactly what's
happening the emotions as I said are
earned in this moment you just feel so
great because the film has built to this
and built to this to the point where it
does not feel forced it feels so
necessary and it just feels right and
I've always loved this line it is
classic Peter Parker hi
hi this is really heavy the ending of
this film is also so so great
MJ chooses not to go forth with this
marriage and it's also good because
Peter is trying to save her by you know
I don't want you to be with me cuz I
have enemies and my bottom line and
she's just like screw you man let me
choose what I want to do with my life
and I want to be with you it's wrong for
us to only feel half alive let's be
together and it's great it's such a
welcome feelings when you watch this
movie it's like oh my god poor Peter
every scene you just feel so sorry for
this guy and at the end it's just like
yes he finally has something good but
that final shot of MJ is so telling
she's just oh I'm alone now and it's
really really well done this movie is
fantastic I have but only a few problems
with it the burning building scene some
of the character motivations don't
always make sense but I do love
spider-man too and as of right now it's
my favorite spider-man movie and I'm
going to give it an a guys thank you so
much for watching my review of
spider-man - I'm gonna have my review of
spider-man 3 for you very soon oh that's
gonna be a fun one I got some stuff to
say about that do the best guys thank
you so much and if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
you